bonjour thomas des rassemblements de
nouveaux rassemblements d'ailleurs sont
prévues aujourd'hui
quel est le programme pour les grévistes
et bien rassemblement est donc prévue en
fin de matinée ici devant le ministère
de l'économie et des finances et en
symboles pour alerter sur les dérives
dénoncées par les syndicats à une dérive
qui le qualifie de purement financière
on est six semaines maintenant après le
début de la grève entamée donc par
certains salariés du groupe sanofi qui a
donc démarré le 19 janvier dernier ils
sont en grève pour dénoncer la casse de
la recherche il faut dire que sanofi
devrait procéder à 1700 suppressions
d'emplois en europe dont 1000 en france
avec notamment des plans de départs
volontaires et puis 400 postes
pourraient être supprimés dans la
branche recherche et développement de
quoi provoquer l'incompréhension de
certains salariés du groupe alors que
nous sommes en pleine pandémie il
réclame l'arrêt des plans de
suppressions d'emplois l'augmentation
des salaires et l'embauché des
intérimaires en cdi alors que ma sanofi
pris dans la tourmente de ce mouvement
social et qui doit aussi faire face à
son inefficacité dans la course au
vaccin
mais certains y voient d'ailleurs un
lien de cause à effet sanofi a annoncé
au mois de janvier dernier que la
livraison de ce vaccin ne se fera pas
avant la fin de l'année 2000 21 c'est
donc bien plus tard que les autres
et malgré les accusations le pdg de
l'entreprise refuse lui de faire le lien
entre la politique de suppressions
d'emplois et ses piètres résultats dans
la course au vaccin mais la stratégie du
groupe est donc remise en question
entreprises françaises qui a pourtant
une grosse expérience dans le domaine
des vaccins qui n'a donc pas su répondre
aux attentes dans cette période de
pandémie pour autant elle a réalisé un
chiffre d'affaires en hausse
l'année dernière et pour récompenser ses
actionnaires l'entreprise sanofi qui a
délivré par moins de 4 milliards d'euros
de dividendes à ses actionnaires un
versement qui passe mal alors que
l'entreprise est en pleine
restructuration et que les emplois sont
donc menacés
merci beaucoup thomas bonnet pour toutes
ces précisions et vous allez suivre
évidemment cette grève donc qui commence
à 10h30 ce matin